the president held that rally last night
in El Paso because it is one of the
largest US cities on the border with
Mexico city officials claim the
president is spreading false information
though about crime and other problems
there Mireya Villarreal is in El Paso
with a closer look at the reality along
the border Matea good morning to you
well good morning you know the president
actually says that border walls like
this one right here in El Paso make city
safer they reduced crimes and they help
save lives but you know right now he's
also saying that he doubled down on that
comment he made in the State of the
Union that El Paso was a dangerous and
violent city before the wall was built
but if you take a look at FBI statistics
from 1985 to 2014 they showed that El
Paso's violent crime rate was
significantly lower than the average for
cities of comparable size President Bush
authorized the existing border fence
here in 2006 and it was construction
actually started in 2008 President Trump
claimed crime rates in El Paso dropped
immediately once the fence was built but
two years after construction began on
the fence the violent crime rate in El
Paso increased by 17 percent
now El Paso's current mayor Republican D
Marcos said that he did credit the wall
for reducing crime and says it helps
with non violent crimes but he also
credits local law enforcement Border
Patrol ice agents with coming together
to keep the community safe
last night President Trump's response to
that was I don't care if the mayor is a
Republican or a Democrat they're full of
crap if they say that walls don't make a
difference be otta and the mayor thank
you very the mayor alone isn't the only
Republican who believes that remember
will Hurd was here he's the only
Republican supporter land and he said
that a wall would not help the situation
either exactly hang out a lot of facts
once again